Surrey police say that an incident at
Epsom College in the early hours of
Sunday morning they've made a statement
about this this of course the discovery
of head teacher Emma Patterson who was
found dead alongside her husband George
and their seven-year-old daughter it is
now being treated as a homicide
investigation a murder investigation
Elena veslenovich is in The Newsroom for
us what can you tell us Melina that's
right sorry police just confirming that
it is now being treated as a murder
investigation they say that they were
caught the ambulance service was called
a ten past one and the police found
three bodies which they're confident are
those of Emma Patterson her
seven-year-old daughter Letty and George
Paterson on side there was also a
firearm that was recovered however the
police say they have to wait for the
completion of the post-mortems later on
this week before they can be confident
to say what the cause of the death was
however that firearm they now say was
registered to George Patterson the
police also say that they had been in
contact with him just days before this
incident on the 2nd of February about
this firearm however that was purely
routine and they are confident that no
one else is involved in this tragic
incident for now